there are only so many major news
stories each year and we have one of
them today and this is actually i would
argue one of the biggest news stories of
the decade we've been waiting for the
supreme court's decision on abortion
rights two cases that historically
establish the right to an abortion in
most cases in the united states those
are roe v wade and planned parenthood v
casey the supreme court we knew sometime
in the next few weeks maybe by the end
of june would issue a decision on a
mississippi abortion ban which would
in practice overturn roe v wade and
planned parenthood vkc depending on what
the court decides and that decision has
been leaked it has not been announced by
the supreme court but it has been leaked
and reputably so
and if nothing changes
the
supreme court will be overturning
abortion rights as a
federal in most cases right
sending it back to the states plunging
many states back into
should we call it medieval times should
we call it the dark ages should we call
it the 1850s the 1950s there are
actually two cases here most people know
about roe v wade but there's two cases
roe v wade as well as the 1992 planned
parenthood decision uh uh supreme court
decision planned parenthood v casey now
politico got a copy of the draft opinion
and this is this is a major scoop it
really is and there are conservatives
mad about the fact that this leaked but
obtaining this is a major scoop and um
the quote from the
majority opinion believed to be ready to
go in a few weeks is from supreme court
justice samuel alito where he writes
quote
ro
was egregiously wrong from the start its
reasoning was exceptionally weak and the
decision has had damaging consequences
and far from bringing about a national
settlement of the abortion issue row and
casey have inflamed debate and deepened
division now before we go forward with
the analysis on the assumption that this
decision isn't going to change we should
put on record in case things do change
that sometimes justices will circulate
draft opinions and there's still
revisions and changes and sometimes
horse trading for votes i mean things
happen you would think that that doesn't
happen at the supreme court but it does
and up until days before it's made
official
opinions can change but right now
roe v wade goes bye-bye
planned parenthood vkc goes bye-bye now
on the issue of blame because i've
gotten a ton of messages from people
about who do we blame here do we blame
the people that didn't vote for hillary
and all this different stuff listen we
most it's like what when there's a uh um
i'm not even gonna make any analogies we
mostly blame the supreme court justices
who voted this way okay that but we
primarily blame them
and when it comes to the supreme court
then you go well why are they there and
so you go to trump we
trump's choices are what made this
a plausible reality and we predicted and
we were worried that it would happen and
it looks like it's happening so we blame
the justices and we blame the president
who put them there who's donald trump
well why was trump there we mostly blame
the people who voted for donald trump
and put him in this position
but we also say hey as an instructive
element
as something we should remember
those people who said hillary trump it's
all the same
it's all the same i'm gonna stay home or
i'm gonna write in whoever because they
said supreme court i don't care about
the supreme court when i was here saying
you realize what could happen if trump
wins and gets to pick supreme court
justices right and some of you said oh i
don't care about that that's not a big
deal
well there is some responsibility there
as well but most of it is the people who
voted for trump and trump and the
supreme court justices that he put there
we don't have to go crazy fighting about
it we just have to remember in case this
comes up again
if you didn't vote for hillary in 2016
this was the risk you assumed i'm not
saying you're a bad person but this was
the risk you assumed you thought it was
worth i don't know sending a message to
the dnc or whatever and that's totally
fine that's your right but this was the
risk you assumed and uh now this is
where we are now the one thing here
that could be a silver lining
i've been saying
democrats are heading towards a
disastrous and potentially historic
defeat in the midterms in november
it's possible possible that this might
be what lights a fire under the left to
say wow now we see the repercussions
we've got to get out there and vote i'll
come back to that um let's go back a
little bit uh you know we we often talk
about how
all supreme court nominees play coy when
asked about abortion and they say well i
might come before the cord and i can't
pre-judge and all these different things
just as a reminder here's samuel alito
back at his confirmation hearing in 2006
kind of dancing around the question of
is abortion constitutionally protected
he said it was not in an earlier writing
before being nominated here's how he
danced around this question during his
confirmation hearings spectre then
brought up the often cited letter alito
wrote in 1985 in applying for a job in
the reagan white house stating the
constitution does not protect a right to
an abortion do you agree with that
statement today uh judge alito
well that was a correct statement of
what i thought in 1985 from my vantage
point in 1985 and that was
as a line attorney in the department of
justice in the reagan administration
today if the issue were to come before
me if i am fortunate enough to be
confirmed and the issue were to come
before me then i would have to i would
approach the question with an open mind
and i would i would listen so you would
approach it with an open mind
notwithstanding
your 1985 statement
absolutely senator that was a statement
that i made at a prior period of time
when i was performing a different role
and as i said yesterday
when when someone becomes a judge you
really have to put aside
the things that you did
as a lawyer
at prior points in your legal career and
and think about legal issues the way a
judge thinks about legal issues
here are trump's three
supreme court nominees amy coney barrett
brett kavanaugh and neil gorsuch when
roe v wade an abortion precedent came up
during their confirmation hearings
is roe a super president how would you
define super precedent and i'm answering
a lot of questions about roe which i
think indicates that roe doesn't fall in
that category and scholars across the
spectrum say that doesn't mean that rose
should be overruled but descriptively it
does mean that it's okay not a case that
everyone has accepted and doesn't call
for its overruling as a judge it is an
important precedent of the supreme court
by it i mean roe v wade and planned
parenthood versus casey
been reaffirmed many times
casey is precedent on precedent
which itself is an important factor
senator as the book explains
um the supreme court of the united
states is held and roe versus wade
that um
a fetus is not a person for purposes of
the 14th amendment
and the book explains that do you accept
that
that's the law of the land i accept the
law of the land center yes
so everybody just kind of playing it off
like i don't know you know there's
precedent it's the law i don't have any
big desire to overturn roe v wade but
now if nothing changes it will be gone
go back to what hillary clinton said
back in 2018 where she said quote
if brett kavanaugh becomes a supreme
court justice will he help gut or
overturn roe v wade which legalized
abortion in america yes
of course he will and she was right and
i am no fan of hillary uh but hillary
was right about many things it turns out
in retrospect this makes donald trump an
extraordinarily consequential president
trump as far as we know personally isn't
even pro-life trump was vocally
pro-choice until he was 68 years old and
then he ran as a republican and had to
come up with this explanation well i met
a kid i liked and the mom said at one
point she thought about aborting and so
then i was pro-life
nobody believes it if you're thinking
critically but it doesn't change that
trump may now be the most consequential
anti-abortion president in history at
this point in time a totally clueless
doofus
but he figured out a way to overturn roe
v wade something i don't think he even
cares about personally this lets each
state decide
do we restrict abortion do we ban
abortion and i've said
it isn't even really clear
what democrats could do to save the
midterms but this reality that states
now could
ban or restrict abortion in absolutely
authoritarian retrograde ways
maybe
it will help democrats not get crushed
in november we talked about what if
biden forgive some student loan debt
what about cannabis decriminalization i
don't know
this could be the thing it is possible
that this is exactly the
earth-shattering wake-up call that might
get people to go out and vote because
they realize this is dark ages stuff
we're leaving the country to retrograde
elements of society to run things and
this issue
could potentially reshape the midterms
and we'll talk about that more protests
are already surging police are setting
up barriers at the supreme court and
this could inspire all sorts of new
voters apathetic voters we just can't
say yet now what do people do in red
states
does everyone with common sense leave
the red states to go to the safe haven
of blue states i don't know do the
leftists flood the red states to make
them no longer red and it is really
quite the situation and you know for us
who live in blue states like new york
much will probably not change that's a
reality but for many people in other
parts of the country it will be a
disaster now what's next
what's next because some of the people
against abortion
are also against
interracial marriage
some of them are against divorce for
religious reasons or at least claim to
be
some of them are against gay adoption
some of them are against gay marriage
they want it to be legal to fire people
for their gender identity or sexual
orientation which by the way is still
legal in more than 20 states they want
to be able to
whatever and once they discover
that you can take away established
rights from people if you put the right
people on the court and do the right
things at the state level to get a case
in front of the supreme court why would
they stop here they're not going to that
is for damn sure so we are going
backwards and next i want to talk a
little bit about the reaction from mega
world
to what we have learned uh overnight
one of our sponsors is curiosity stream
the only subscription streaming service
that specializes in documentaries my
audience can get a curiosity stream
subscription for only about a dollar a
month at curiositystream.com
pacman we all know netflix then hulu
they have some documentaries but
curiosity stream has a way better
selection in every category i'm always
finding documentaries on curiosity
stream i can't find anywhere else i just
watched electing lincoln which is a
three-part series about what led to the
election of abraham lincoln fascinating
absolutely fascinating curiosity stream
has an app for all of your devices i've
always got it going on the tv or i can
do put it on my tablet when i travel
with curiositystream i can explore a new
topic i never knew i'd be interested in
or
zone out with a great nature documentary
whatever you're looking for it's there
and you can get curiosity stream for
just 14.99 a year that's less than two
bucks a month when you go to
curiositystream.com pacman and use the
code pacman the link is down below